[Music]
thanks for being here I'm Anthony Pass
smart I lead the product management team
for cloud IOT at Google and I'm joined
by a few folks here so Sastry the CTO
from foghorn remya a VP of Product and
Scott Bracken from Honeywell so we're
gonna talk a little bit about some of
the stuff we've been doing with with
foghorn and Honeywell so a bit of an
agenda little overview of Google and how
we see IOT fairly high-level and generic
view of IOT for us and then for Cornwell
come on stage and talk about their edge
solution and there is a core integration
which is pretty cool you'll see some of
the platform and they're gonna talk
about a use case they've done with
Honeywell and they actually have a nice
demo here to show you what they've done
which is really impressive and I think
adds a lot of value so we'll have the
demo and Q&A at the end so I hope you
enjoy so you're probably here because
you all know that IOT can and probably
is already bringing value to your to
your businesses and whether it's to
solve something specific or to really
being part of a broader digital
transformation it's really central to a
lot of know creating differentiation for
your businesses and across the
industries we see that in agriculture
really know increasing crop yield or
lowering energy consumption in oil and
gas doing predictive maintenance or
security in oil and gas since all those
use cases we're seeing logistics to do
high-value asset tracking or better
driving behaviors for fleets reducing
risk for the drivers so we see a lot of
those use cases almost across every
industry and we're seeing our two use
cases what we've seen also that's a
study that came out this is a IOT
analytics company that does does a bunch
of competitive intelligence on IOT and
in different sectors what they're saying
is about no in 2021 about 50% that
company will have IOT projects and will
have seen value so it's more than having
a projects actually seen value for my ot
in 2021 that's about know only two years
from now
but what's staggering is different from
2018 to 2021 there's a massive
difference and massive growth in the
realization of value through IOT which
is the big change here I'm going to talk
a little bit about real-time in some of
the talk because we're seeing we're
seeing that speed is really critical in
IOT you know we've seen analytics done
on both data on data base and that's
great to build your models but what
we're seeing from customers is really
the demand for real-time insights and
real-time actionable insight actually
and what's important it we're seeing
that data by 2025 a quarter of the data
will be a real-time in nature so that's
quite a lot but as part of that quarter
of data a 95% of is actually IOT data
that's real-time IOT data from the
global data sphere they call it's kind
of funky word but interesting so
real-time nature being able to take
decision right there on the spot either
locally or in the cloud is super
important for an IOT platform and it
really it's it's it's more important
even because you want to get that
accuracy you know to reduce cost dry
efficiency on a manufacturing line to
simplify your logistics and reduce risk
and make your environment work more safe
so that's something we've seen you know
in and gas in particular you know to
track workers with their heart and know
being in zones they're supposed to be
and things like that this is vision
intelligence apply to to a work
environment for safety use cases that
has to happen in real time you can't
wait for the next day to say hey you
should have been there the accident
happens too late one thing that we've
noticed and I've been in the in that in
that cloud IOT space for quite some time
now and I've seen it going through a lot
of cycles of POC II and pilots and
testing out stuff I think that's
changing now I'm seeing the POCs and the
pilots go to production and that's a big
shift that we're seeing we're seeing
those growth you know people the
comedies I've been testing IOT for a
while now they realize what they can do
with it and now it's going in production
let
a big shift we're seeing and the problem
is you really have to think about okay
am I am i doing my IT project in
isolation am I using the right PI for
I'm not limited by the platform using am
i restricting my possibilities with a
platform I chose so choosing choosing
they are the provider of your IT
platform is actually really important
and you often time forget about the
delays of managing complex
infrastructure when you put IT platform
in place the specialized tech and
learning curve you have to have for
hardware communication ai a data
ingestion and all of that there's no
real standard protocols it's pretty
messy there's a lot of hidden cost that
come with with a without your T
deployment so having a platform that's
simple flexible and can really help you
to get to value faster is critical for
the success we see IOT from Google sign
what we see our T as a big data
challenge almost more than anything else
and big data in real-time and having
that ability to gain real-time insight
as I said we'll bring the
competitiveness that you're looking for
for your business so in terms of
platform the Google Cloud IOT platform
is a serverless platform from
connectivity processing storage and
analyze serverless means that you never
have to worry about scaling up or down
or you know pre provisioning resources
and overusing resources it's just gonna
scale from one or a few device to
millions of devices very easily and
that's really a core differentiation of
our platform from connectivity to an
analysis if we look a little bit deeper
into the cloud iot platform itself
you're gonna see several components here
the main one is cloud IOT core that's
something we launched GA last year in
March so about a year ago that's been
pretty successful this is a global
front-end for your devices one you're
well globally and we use all the Google
front end the GFE will call them to
ingest data from anywhere in the world
you don't really have to think about
where is my device physically in which
region does it have to connect you to
have the lowest latency that will happen
animatic
this is served by the same front-end
that serve your Google search or your
YouTube it's the same throne and so it's
really global really scalable all across
the globe once the data flows into IOT
core it flows into pot Sub Pop says is
this messaging bus global again also
realized you not have to worry about
resources here pops up is available
globally that means that if you have
data ingested in Australia in Asia in
North America they all fall into a topic
of your choice if you want to get that
air just query that topic and get the
data out you don't have to think about
oh where is my device again it's all
global infrastructure automatically
scalable pub/sub stores data for seven
days you can do snapshot replays and
have several subscribers to it and get
the data the data can go into a crowd
function a server let's go compute
service to trigger actions or do any
kind of request or can go to cloud data
fusion a cloud data fusion is the
managed version of sadef sadef is an
open-source data processing pipeline it
is you may know it as cask dot IO so
that's open source and you can create
your workflow with drag and drop little
nodes and then do your transformation
along the oil plug that plug the data
out pops up to your transformation and
drop it in some database if you want to
do longer processes like windowing
analysis in real time you can use data
flow data flow is also scalable on its
own and has an Apache Beam open source
equivalent all those are kind of have
managed but have their open source
equivalents pretty cool and then you
learn in BigTable if you want to do time
series if you want to do big data
analytics you have your bigquery you
have cloud machine learning to do your
training
send those models back and send them
back to the device because podiatric
core is bi-directional and then you have
some nice visualization tools so that's
what we call the cloud IOT platform
putting that together is fairly simple
doesn't require much code if any code
it's also realized and we're pretty
happy with some of the some of the early
customers that we've had you can see
some of this customer at the spotlight
session on Thursday
have some of the customer on stage one
key element of our strategy with Google
Cloud IOT platform is we can't do it on
our own we have to have partners working
with us and I'm really happy today to
have for corn as one of our partners
if sastra wants to join me for corn
we've been working with them for over a
year at the edge in particular and
solving some of our edged challenges and
doing machine learning at the edge so
thank you I'll leave it up to my sister
thank you is what makeup do you run good
evening good afternoon everyone I know
I'm between you and food so I'll try to
be as interesting as possible so we are
a Google partner as you mentioned and we
are an edge computing platform provider
company we are a valley based company
I'm going to give you a snapshot of who
we are we're based in Sunnyvale right
here in the valley we provide software
that runs on small devices edge devices
whether they are existing plcs gateways
or embedded systems close to the
machines close to the assets and the key
here is to do live data processing
analytics and machine learning on the
data that's flowing through the edge to
derive actionable insights we've got
customers across the globe hundreds of
them we've got lots of analyst coverage
and so on every one that you see here in
the logos these are already investors
Honeywell is an investor Honeywell is
actually going to talk today about how
they're leveraging our technology for
some of the use cases as well you can
see all of the big technology and
industrial names there as well that all
our investments traditionally we have
been shipping our products on gateways
PLC's raspberry PI's things of that
nature where you have a flavor of Linux
or Windows or a real-time operating
system what we have recently also done
is release the same product on handheld
devices which is actually the cool part
of the demo and the session today on
Android based devices so the way the
product works is this is how it looks
like you have a tool here in the cloud
which you use to manage all of the edge
devices the software runs on the edge
device itself we have a very flexible
micro services based architecture in the
traditional Linux world we have used
containers obviously in Android there
are no container so we have the
all of this as an app so the notion that
you can have all kinds of data that fed
into our system through a data bus that
we have the two core key components here
or the analytics engine and the edge ml
the machine learning engine the idea
being that as you are ingesting a live
data from all different sources you can
apply analytics and machine learning on
the on the data to derive the insights
and then you can take closed-loop
control actions by either using our SDK
there is an SDK using which you can
build applications or you can also
visualize it and send that information
into IOT core in other places as well so
maybe let's step back a second a lot of
you I'm sure many of you are familiar
with edge computing but let's step back
for a second to say why is edge actually
important right so in a typical
industrial environment where there's an
oil and gas manufacturing transportation
smart cities building doesn't matter all
of these different sectors you've got
data coming in I might add lots of data
especially if you're doing video audio
and acoustic type of data and there is a
high cost latency and security
associated with it viable by directly
connecting these machines into some kind
of a central location what fukin really
does is to help with that solve the
problem by introducing this edge device
right next to the asset on many cases on
the asset itself where the data is
ingested into our software running here
and then you derive the insights and
then send the results in insights back
into the cloud where for additional
processing for function your models for
fleet-wide visibility and and so on this
obviously has the benefits of low
latency here because there is no latency
involved between these two and then
there is low cost of data transport and
then security is also eliminated or
minimized when you're communicating with
that another way to look at it a lot of
the times when you're processing data in
this example right here this is a sensor
signal for one of the signals you see
here how the blips are in the signal
this is a suction pump when you
typically send that information to a
downsampled environment whether it's
cloud datacenter this signal actually
looks like that you actually pretty much
missed our little point of water days
so the fidelity of deriving the insights
actionable insights at the edge is a lot
higher is really why it's so important
in addition to all of the three things
that I talked about security cost and of
course latencies
this is the high level product solution
which is our traditional solution that
we've been shipping on Linux it's the
same solution that I showed you on the
first slide has been ported on to
Android then the idea here is being that
you ingest it data from all these
different types of sources and reach
them because a lot of the times in the
industrial world the data quality is not
good that layer fixes all of that
cleanses normalizes decodes it and then
does processing through these two layers
that I talked about and then the
information itself can then be published
to a cloud environment we have pretty
deep integration with IOT core as
Anthony mentioned and I'll mention that
in a second in the next slide how that
is done as well and using the - DK you
can then program and programmatically
subscribe to those insights and take
closed-loop actions so one concept that
I want to bring into this picture is
this notion of what is called education
I know it's a new word so what is
education a lot of the times when you
build data science models machine
learning models to run in in a server
environment cloud environment you may or
may not necessarily pay attention to the
amount of compute resources or you may
be actually working on batch data rather
than working on live data and you may
also not pay attention to the number of
layers on the size of the model because
those are not necessarily the
constraints you worry about in a cloud
environment but when you bring the same
model to run on an edge environment in
order to run efficiently and also
perform at the rate that you would
expect you have to deal with those
things and that process is what we call
education how do you take your model
that typically works off of batch data
and make it run on real time live data
how do you then optimize and reduce the
number of layers and the weights and
still with the same level of accuracy
and finally if you look at the anatomy
of a machine learning model it has
really three things one is
we call a pre-processing curve which is
really feature extraction let's say
looking at a video or are you looking at
some sensor signals from the machines
before you can apply a machine learning
model an algorithm you gotta extract
some features and that's typically what
we call pre-processing and that is the
most compute-intensive part of it and
then followed by you've passed those
features into your machine learning
algorithm or the equation which itself
is not really that computationally
intensive and then followed by what a
post-processing which is how do you then
take the results of that equation do
something with it what we do as part of
a certification process is to extract
out all of the pre-processing the
post-processing into our highly
efficient complex event processing
engine that we built from ground up
which runs in really really small
fitment few megabytes of memory runs
really fast and then leave the machine
learning port equation to it into your
engine of course you also have the
ability to in fact do the machine
learning part in the CEP engine itself
as we move forward here are some
examples where we took a video based
flare modeling use case how you can
actually optimize when you build take a
model that's built here identify it you
got almost a 10x or higher improvement
and yet much higher fidelity much higher
accurate results now even when you build
a machine learning model to derive some
insights and predict some things and you
deploy this in the edge environment or
any amount for that matter and it's
accurately predicting the results it
does not necessarily mean over time it's
going to continue to predict with the
same level of accuracy because of data
drifts because of changes in the machine
behavior the same model that once used
to accurately predict the results may no
longer do that so how do we how do we
address that how do we fix that to
address that we came up with this notion
of automated closed loop machine
learning so what does that really mean
so as you see here in our architecture
once a model is deployed we built this
thing called the prediction model
degradation detector what that module
does is that it continuously measures
several different factors whether it's
an f1 score
whether it's a data distribution
collection how things are and tries to
see if the accuracy
the model that you're predicting is
deviating from what it was before and
when it does what it does is
automatically sends that information to
the Google IOT core here from Google IIT
core as Anthony explained it's a pub/sub
system you can send that information to
dataflow and then which can then be read
and configured into bigquery and the
cloud ml engine where you retrain
incrementally your model with this
incremental data that's coming in and
then push the model back on onto on to
the edge engine as well this is all
automated of course you have an option
to not automate it but this is done an
automated way until the accuracy comes
back to what it was before and this is
what we've been calling the closed loop
per ml I know different terminals have
been used this is truly revolutionizing
the edge computing because you're
actually introducing the notion of AI
artificial intelligence onto the judge
devices on how do you self-correct how
do you self correct the models deployed
on to this environment in order for you
to continue to predict this with the
same level of accuracy as you can see we
are our solution is a generic platform
we have been deploying this across many
many use cases across many different
verticals our top verticals actually
include manufacturing a lot of big-name
customers oil and gas transportation
smart cities buildings we have done
other things as well like mining and so
on what I want to do is just mention a
couple of use cases quickly here in the
one in the manufacturing one in oil and
gas that actually involves different
paradigms this is a factory I can
publicly reference it's a GE factory
they manufacture this industrial grade
capacitors that looked like this this is
a highly expensive capacitors that are
used in power plants the material cost
alone is several thousand dollars and
the way the processing includes was they
take an aluminum foil they wounded
through what is called a winding machine
Kollmorgen warning machine and the
binding machine itself has hundreds of
sensors that are continuously measuring
several things winder tension with the
aspect ratio and so on once they winded
they press it into packs and then insert
it these are those paths and they run it
through what is called a treat oven to
take out all the moisture content and
finally they fill oil into the capacitor
to test the capacitor
at this point if the capacitor fails
light is not working or seeing
dielectric failures is too late in the
process and that's exactly what was
happening in the factory as they walked
into the factory I see a lot of pink
slips on the factory floor costing them
lotta scrap millions of dollars so the
challenge for us was how do we connect
our Ed's solution to the sensors
directly into this assembly line in the
machine connected and identify exactly
what was causing these dielectric
failures more importantly before it is
too late
so that the operator actually has a
chance to go take the units offline and
then fix it and that's what we've been
able to successfully do that and reduce
all of their pain points on the scrap
the second use case I want to talk about
is interesting this is an oil and gas
use case we have Saudi Aramco it's one
of our customers many other customers as
well we've actually publicly talked
about this at the ERC conference a
couple of months ago this is as some of
you may be familiar with like in oil gas
refineries
gas is being refined you've got hundreds
of compressors and because of various
reasons excessive pressure sometimes
other reasons compressor failures the
gas gets released in through what are
called oil stacks these are called oil
starts and then the gas gets burnt when
the gas gets burned you see a fire
what's worse you can see smoke sometimes
fight itself is bad smoke is even worse
dark smoke is even worse right so how to
identify up until before this edge
solution came up typically they install
video cameras sometimes sometimes they
don't even do that and a human being is
able to monitor 24 by 7 which is not
really practical all they can do is to
see all there is fire there is more what
we have done is installed our software
on a controller box attached to this
these oil stacks many many many of them
and then directly take the video feed
from this combine it with the audio feed
of the compressor and identify and
correlate when there is in fact a floor
flare or a smoke or and also compute the
volumetric flow of the gas that is born
and things of that nature so human being
and monitoring of this is eliminated but
more importantly operator gets an alert
when there is a real problem and we get
to the root cause and why the problem
was occurring this was being widely
deployed in a very popular use case one
last thing I want to say is that this
particular
session the rest of the talk and the
demo remember as we talked about is our
product that was released on the
handheld devices mobile X platforms we
have noticed that there is obviously a
lot of traction in this in this field
because you these are all
battery-powered devices which makes it
even more important for our edge
computing to consume less and less power
less and less CPU and memory and we put
it our software onto these devices and
deploying that with the Honeywell
especially initially working with an
evil device where we have done a couple
of use cases which we'll demonstrate
today as well with that I'd like to
invite Scott breakn director of advanced
technology from Honeywell to speak about
their technology take great thank Thank
You Cerie hello everyone my name is
Scott Bracken is faster mentioned and I
lead the advanced technology group for
the productivity products team within
Honeywell and I'd like to introduce you
to the corporation of Honeywell a little
bit to explain where the prototypic
products group sits within Honeywell
it's an exciting time to be an engineer
at HUD Honeywell because there's a
significant amount of growth in being
driven by technology in these four
business segments that Honeywell exists
aerospace homeland building technologies
safety and productivity solutions which
is the group I'm from and I'll explain a
little more about that in a moment and
the performance of materials group the
one common thing that that connects all
of these systems are all of these
business groups is the fact that
connected solutions are what's driving
the growth in all these business areas
and therefore the technology development
within Honeywell it is able to develop
common platforms across these different
businesses and as I mentioned we've been
growing significantly in the technology
area and most specifically transforming
the Honeywell Corporation to a software
industrial business the point of this
slide is to point out that we have
already invested heavily in software
engineering talent within our
corporation to build that capability now
diving a little bit deeper into the
safety and productivity solutions group
you can see that there's a lot of areas
within the industrial sector where
technology can help our
be more productive first in the
connected worker many wearable devices
that a an employee can wear in a in a
industrial setting can help monitor for
safety and to help that employee be more
productive in the supply chain and
logistics area there's a tremendous
amount of data that is important to our
end customers for managing the
efficiency of their operations in the
distribution center themselves we have a
lot of automation that we've introduced
and provide to our customer base again
for reducing their cost of operations
and being more efficient and finally we
also have a very wide portfolio of
sensors primarily for sense for safety
applications pressure sensors and gas
detection type sensors are quite
prominent in that portfolio but we have
sensors that support all the different
IOT applications across this suite so
once again diving a little bit deeper
into the Honeywell technology area
specifically in productivity products
what am I talking about in that realm
there's several different solutions and
many customers use this technology in
different ways but we can provide common
platforms across these use cases to
provide those customers with the unique
needs that they have yet with the power
and the of having a very robust a
solution underneath things such as
vehicle-mounted computers all types of
asset tracking technologies particularly
RFID sensing is is seeing a growth spurt
in recent years this is not just limited
to some of the industrial settings but
also spills over into retail quite
prominently and then looking at the
solutions on the right-hand of this
chart you know scanning is really at the
core of what we've what we do in our
productivity products group right
product identification primarily with
barcodes is what our scanning devices is
centered around and then we provide
value on top of that with other
solutions such as voice solutions to
allow for hands-free operation of
product identification the mobile
computers which I'll go into in a little
more detail in a moment
and then of course different tagging
that we can use for sensing the devices
in any kind of inventory setting
that all gets tied together obviously in
a cloud environment for data management
and inventory tracking purposes and most
recently in fact in the last year our
flagship device was recently introduced
we call it our mobility edge platform
and its unified platform for mobile
computing it's based on the Android or
you know it's an Android based device
and it's purpose-built for these
industrial applications
the ruggedized design of not only the
form factor being very familiar to
employees but also the allowing for a
very heavy use during a workday
you know as I mentioned product
identification and barcode scanning is
the core operation of these devices but
that can take place thousands of times a
day or thousands of times in a single
shift so building a device that can
handle that kind of workload survive the
entire shift is a very critical aspect
of our our customer requirements so
withstanding you know the harsh
environment whether it's you know impact
or whether it's the elements even a
moisture and say a a rain rainy
environment you can also withstand we've
used an Android operating system
obviously for easy field deployment and
giving us very a seamless operation with
the cloud connectivity and we built this
device with multiple form factors but
underneath the hood is a single common
hardware platform and I particularly
like this slide myself because I'm
surrounded by software engineers but
actually I'm a hardware engineer at my
roots and so I have to at least show at
least one slide with a with a processor
module on it and we're quite proud of
this processor module that we introduced
with the mobility edge platform last
year because it is common throughout all
the different form factors of the
different mobile devices that we provide
to our customer base and particularly
I'm excited today to be on stage with
Google and with Foghorn because now that
we've deployed this edge device this
platform we we now can build a
tremendous amount of value within the
software on top of that device and the
and the first place we starter one
first place we started is looking for
this very thin layer that Sastri's has
already described that allows us to
build the AI and machine learning
toolset and capability on top of these
on top of these mobility edge devices
and and foghorns lightning offering
meets all of those requirements for our
needs
across our entire customer set so now
the last couple of slides before I hand
it off to the demo are just describing
the use cases that we are first
investing in the first one is quite an
interesting one to us because we have a
rich history of designing a very
sophisticated software tool decoder tool
to extract from an image a barcode and
decode it for that customer's
application but on the edge of that
application and during different use
cases many of the images we receive from
our device on our imager come in very
blurry or very noisy it's very common
new operators that haven't operated as
scanner before you know don't
necessarily aim the device accurately or
I'm sure many of you have been at a
retail store when when a particular
packaging maybe a shrink wrap packaging
that has some ripple in it is is causing
the scan to be difficult to read for
that device and an operator naturally
many times wants to go closer to that
barcode to pick up that scan and in fact
they're making it more blurry by going
closer so again there's several
different environments where a blurry
barcode or being able to decode a blurry
barcode would be much more efficient for
our customer base and as what you see
here is a data set so we created a
synthetic data set of 50,000 images
barcode images were they are image pairs
clean images and blurry or damaged
images and we use that for training our
machine learning model that then we
deployed through the foghorn system onto
our mobile led edge device and these are
just some snippets of the images that
were part of our training data set so
that's our first use case
and our second one is very is it's quite
basic but very important to our
customers so these devices are owned by
the customer they're not owned by the
employee they're not their personal
devices so the typical method for these
being deployed is at the beginning of a
shift the operator will take the device
use it throughout the shift and then
docket for charging overnight the very
simple requirement is is that device
must operate continuously throughout
that entire shift that shift can vary in
time it can vary in in operation and
what what modes are being used and so by
applying the machine learning type of
approach to this and working with the
data scientists at Foghorn we're able to
create a real-time operating model on on
the mobility edge device that can
monitor and optimize to extend the life
of that battery for that device during
the shift so with that I'd like to
invite Rami up from Foghorn VP of
products to take us through the demo all
right I'm here to tell you that it's
real so this is the Honeywell device
it's a CT 60 and our Falcon lightning
mobile is actually running on this so
following up from Scott's talk what I
will demo here are the two apps one is
the battery insight app and the other
one is the barcode optimization right
but before we jump to the app what I do
want to do I am a products person is go
through our Foghorn manager here
so what do you see on this side on the
left side here is our Foghorn manager
portal so think of it as our remote
management configuration monitoring
console and let you see all the edge
devices that have the Lightning mobile
or the Lightning stack installed on it
well one of the things we do at Foghorn
is be very focused on the OT persona
right we understand the users of our
product our operators in the
manufacturing floor your refinery
technician and so a lot of what we put
in here is focused on that personnel so
especially in manufacturing rate the
idea is to create this one gold
configuration that can work across
massive volumes of devices and so this
foghorn manager portal lets you create
that configuration whether it's to you
know add a new sensor define analytic
expressions that do complex event
processing or come up with machine
learning models all of that is packaged
up really nicely into a configuration
and deploy it onto the device and so
that's what we've done here so you can
see the two solutions which is the
barcode enhancer and the battery
insights there are the two models that
are part of this configuration and now
that's what's deployed on this device so
let me pull up the foghorn app so you
can see the four hand app here
that's installed on this device and
immediately we have the two solutions
pop up which is the barcode enhancer and
the battery insights now Scott did talk
about the the goal of using battery
insights and I'll talk a little bit
about the the metrics that show up here
so one of these apps represent two
classes of learning so to speak right in
the battery insights app it's an
adaptive learning model that's that's
going on on this device right so it's
learning on the fly based on the pattern
of usage how often is the battery
charged how long is the work shift like
how does the user actually use it what
we are building is a very unique
fingerprint of device usage that is
specific to this unit so the metric here
is saying yeah it's okay for the shift
right it's gonna last this battery is
gonna last for the next 16 hours oh by
the way also in for you that your work
shift is around 8 hours so this model is
gonna get better and better as the
device gets used over time now if you
move on to the next one which is the
barcode enhancer it happens behind the
scenes right so this is the nopper ATAR
he has the scanner he's scanning the
barcode and the the goal is to have that
first can be successful
and in the event that's far talked about
the image is grainy what happens is that
gets passed to the formstack right and
we're running this neural net model so
the difference in the model is that's a
New Relic model
using tensorflow running on tensorflow
light and the influencing is happening
on the device so to help demonstrate how
the barcodes actually look before and
after the neural net model runs through
it I'll actually go through a barcode
viewer enhancer app here so on the top
here you see the before picture like
this is what the operator is actually
seen when they scan the barcode and once
it passes through the lightning mobile
stack here this is the result
there is definitely much more clarity
and more importantly there's no loss of
productivity when the operator tries to
do that first scan
there's no manual reentry of the code so
let me go through a couple of more
images this is an example of a full bar
code sample and this is the clarified
one through our stack this is one of my
favorites it's a piece of the barcode I
didn't I didn't think I'd ever see I
have a favorite bar code but here it is
there we go and I think now to do that
is the last one so the point of this
presentation is to say that we have
lightning mobile and we have the ability
to now run on Honeywell devices with the
Google cloud technique of doing building
AI models on their data science platform
what does it do for us as industrial
operators as industrial users right it
opens up this whole universe this whole
expanse of use-cases
eos we talked a little bit about sensor
fusion in the past that is it's the
ability to combine video audio
structured data and what are the newer
insights for example if you are from oil
and gas and you have a technician
walking around in your refinery he could
take an Android mobile device point at a
valve and really get inside of it should
this valve be on or off right if the
question masked oneself is what is the
use case today that's tethering my
operator to maybe a location instead
with the
of Android devices is now more liberated
and therefore the ability to get me
really sites
[Music]